parent près de lumbres et de georges
brassens à fait une surprise à la
bretagne très inattendu puisque c'est
toi de naissance et de coeur
il a décidé de s'installer dans un petit
village des côtes du nord au bord de la
mer lézardrieux
c'est là qu'il prépare sa prochaine
rentrée à paris le 10 octobre sur la
scène de bobino
après deux ans d'absence il ya combien
de temps vous et cette maison ici à les
adresser mes phrases en bretagne depuis
une bonne quinzaine
j'ai cherché une maison au bord de l'eau
gelée aussi l'hiver oui je préfère
l'hiver je vis mieux avec les gens du
pays vers quelle votre emploi du temps
quand vous êtes ici pour le moment on
emploi du temps c'est sans les chansons
sinon je le fais semblant de bricoler
dans le jardin récemment c'est aux
fleurs mais pas vraiment pas
passionnément non non ne s'est pas dit
pas très doué pour ça pour faire pousser
les shows et la fleuriste jeu m'a fait
des lilas dangereux belle
applaudissements je n'achète que deux
villas quand je fais mes chances ici
disponible pour tout le reste
quand je fais toujours s est-il
indisponible pour les chansons enfin je
ne peux pas faire prendre les choses à
la fois il se tourne et je me dois
préparer je m'étais légère mais j'avais
pris mon élan quand même depuis depuis
deux trois ans j'avais créé pas mal de
paroles mais c'est la mise au point qui
est longue et difficile et les musiques
en général je suis quand même un peu un
peu toujours assez négligent assez
désinvolte et il faut vraiment je sois
forcé des crimes et musique
et là je suis forcée par le temps donc
sur la chanson pour moi toujours été une
passion depuis l'enfance à la chanson
devenue un métier par la suite c'est
dommage d'ailleurs ma fac elle voudra
méthodique quand vous préparez
précisément vos chansons
non non pas tellement en général de
février d'abord les paroles et d'abris
après la musique l'enfant il m'arrive de
temps en temps des noms ne tue pas de
méthodique du touch attaqué une chanson
et si je sèche de ces jeunes attaquent
une autre mais pas les chats sont les
paroles en même temps parfois cela
arrive mais pas toujours c'est arrivé au
début maintenant comme je compose la
musique assez spontanément et au début à
me je n'ai naturellement sur mes paroles
maintenant il faut quand même qu'il ya
un peu la chercher où aller que seules
celles où aller est ce que vous êtes de
ceux qui disent je vais mettre au
travail à telle heure ou alors c'est à
n'importe quel moment de la journée lui
et je me le dis mais c'était pas du tout
efficace
je me le dis j'essaie de m'astreindre un
peu la force un peu mais ça vous est un
lève tôt très tôt et 4 5 heures je ne
chante pas mais je me promenais le matin
j'ai toujours aimé ça de l'enfant je me
levais tôt même bien la lumière note la
ligne après fiez vous préférez
travailler seul a vendu seul comme je
fais mes paroles ma musique que je
chante que je m'accompagne
mais difficile de le travailler
autrement il accorder plus d'importance
aux paroles ou à la chanson dont les
deux hauts lieux de ont à peu près une
égale importance il semble que les
paroles prédomine chez moi c'est vrai
néanmoins si je chantais le gorille
quand on a dit qu'elle était facile
comme musique su enchanter par exemple
c'est à travers de larges et les
femelles lui quand on contemple et ne
serait pas pareil
on s'apercevrait que la musique quand
même une petite importance
je m'arrange pour comme l impression que
la musique n'existe pas je fais un peu
comme si sur une scène de film we con
quand on ajoute une musique musique sur
une scène sur une séquence au cinéma il
faut que le public l'entente de cette
musique mais qui ne soit pas trop tenté
de l'écouter il faut qu'il la qui la
subissent et je suis je fais en sorte
que même que ma musique souligne un peu
mes paroles mais sans trop s'en prendre
le pas sur elle ce qui vous est arrivé
de commencer les chansons sur les
terminer sans avoir pu déterminer
puis depuis toujours toujours comme ça
derrière moi une vingtaine de chansons
qui y verront peut-être le jour que je
n'arrive pas fini il n'est pas réussie
et à ce moment vous avez une préférée
parmi les nouvelles n'ont fait je n'ai
jamais je ne préfère jamais je les aime
toutes
et puis après qu'un selon les goûts du
public je m'aligne un peu sur le public
peut pas faire autrement mais parfois il
m'arrive aussi d' aimer passionnément et
chansons que le public ne reçoit pas à
pas l'air d'un n'a pas l'air d'accepter
trop et ça vous touche à ce moment là oh
non c'est pas très grave
jeanne et d'autre je suis la mauvaise
and the brave gens rabot gens c'est pas
moi qu'on ruminer c'est pas moi qu'on
met en jeu la balle au bond chez les
autres
braves gens bravo jean et me fit grâce à
moi c'est immoral et c'est comme ça et
je me demande pourquoi bon vieux ça vous
dérange que le suivent à peu et je me
demande pourquoi bon dieu à bout des
reins juive
on dit souvent que je croise à sa tête
paul caractère facile est ce que c'est
vrai ça non non non c'est histoire les
gens ce qui s'est avoué mais surtout
qu'on vous laisse tranquille
pas tellement non je n'aime pas je ne
recherche pas les perdre et on enfin je
ne suis pas tellement non puis je vous
dis c'est tout ceci est une légende je
crois que je suis le meilleur qu'un
tiers de la jasse demain bonjour
quelqu'un l'a écrit peut-être suis-je un
peu gêné devant les caméras pas trop à
mon âge en scène dans tout cela concourt
à donner à créer cette image de l'ours
qui est absolument fausse ou ceux qui
montent à prochaine au village sans
prétention je vais mauvaise réputation
je me démène ou que je reste coi je
passe pour un je ne sais quoi je ne fais
pourtant
de tora personnes
en suivant mon chemin de petit bonhomme
mais les braves gens n'aiment pas que
l'on suive une autre route qu'eux non
les braves gens n'aiment pas que l'on
suive une autre route qu'eux